hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence
je t'attends rejoint moins vite sur
messenger il super truc les copains
l'arcal huit machines bénifique le métro
grande très grande brasserie trop trop
étouffée la soie les poils n'ont as toi
ça c'est une horreur vive le laser et
brocolis charkia j'adore ça j'adore les
milieux coupe du monde va recaler les
bleus les années 90 et mes gars là non
parce que j'aime bien c'est une mauvaise
plat d'or cyril hanouna c'est la famille
jusqu'à ne reparte calme nférieure
j'aime bien ce côté hardcore régate web
des to be free d'arc ja compatriote
collègues des années 90 c'est une grosse
pense à j